Speaker 1: Hey, I don't you if you know me.
You know, I love a good conspiracy theory.
I just.
I just really do.
And one that is really funny is about reptilians.
Now, maybe you don't know what reptilian is
that like a reptile?
Well, it's like a reptile.
Human sort of blend.
Like a reptile.
Reptile like humanoid.
This comes from a number of different places,
but where we most recently saw it, this is
crazy.
Eric BOLLING is now a Newsmax host.
Newsmax is a crazier version of Fox News.
Eric BOLLING actually used to be on Fox News.
Now he wasn't like a serious reporter.
I'm not going to say that.
But he was on Fox News.
He was ultimately pushed out of Fox News because
of sexual harassment allegations against him.
On Newsmax, he seriously devoted a segment
to maybe former President Barack Obama was
a reptilian.
Check this out.
Speaker 3: Back in 2013.
You know that you see that Obama visited the
Middle East and gave a speech, an ordinary
speech, but allegedly a reptilian was identified
in the crowd, a Secret Service agent with
very unique features.
Either way, people ran with it.
And if you can believe this, they even created
a list on how to identify lizard people.
Interesting.
Obama did have low blood pressure.
He doesn't wear glasses.
He does love science.
Oh, that's right.
Remember when he invited that kid to the White
House?
Aspiring little scientist who made a clock,
built it into a suitcase, wires hanging out
all over with a countdown.
All very alarming, don't you think?
And he submitted the project to school.
Well, the worst thing could have happened.
The suitcase started beeping.
People thought it was a bomb.
The teacher called the cops.
Parents were upset.
It was all a whole ordeal.
But I bet if Clark had brought that to the
White House and announced it would ruffle
some feathers now.
Okay.
Speaker 1: So Eric BOLLING barely able to
read off of the teleprompter.
Some people are saying that he's not taking
the conspiracy theory seriously.
Others are saying he clearly is.
It kind of doesn't matter.
The fact that they're even explaining, talking
about these claims in this way is absolutely
bizarre.
So for those who don't know, I really do love
this stuff.
Reptilian conspiracy theories, they're sometimes
they call them reptiles, reptiles, AIDS or
lizard people.
These are supposedly reptilian humanoids.
And the idea of reptilians goes back to David
Icky.
David Icky is a conspiracy theorist who has
claimed that shapeshifting reptilian aliens
control Earth because they take on a human
form.
So they pass as humans, and then they use
their intelligence combined with their fake
human form to gain political power.
And then they manipulate human societies.
And Icky has previously stated that there
are lots of world leaders either who are reptilian
or are possessed by or controlled by reptilians.
And there are adherents of the Q and on conspiracy
theory who borrow a lot of stuff from Reptilians,
you know, with with all of these things.
This is a particularly funny one to me.
Now I know that you can say this one is damaging
in the sense that the people that believe
it often are also anti-Semitic.
They talk about, you know, globalists, globalist.
Yeah.
And all of this stuff.
But by itself it's just kind of dumb.
And of course, we have to at some point apply
an Occam's razor to it.
This just seems really complicated.
And if they could take on this human form,
why would they do it in a way that they would
be identifiable?
Like that infamous video?
It's like a weird, grainy angle of some Secret
Service agent that he was talking about that's
really old that they've brought that up before.
Why would they take such a reptilian form?
If they have such advanced technology and
they're so smart, why couldn't they just design
it so that they look past like humans?
I mean, none of it makes sense, but the fact
that Newsmax is putting this stuff up as if
it's really a topic of discussion shows us
how far we've fallen.
It's even beyond Fox News, I think, although
maybe not, I'd have to go back and review
some of the Fox News segments.
Eric BOLLING from fox news host to sexual
harassment claims to getting fired.
Although officially they parted ways amicably
to spreading ideas about Reptilians on Newsmax.
My How the Mighty Have Fallen.
Remember that on Monday, Memorial Day, we
will have a one day membership special.
We can offer you this special only on a holiday
because our entire team will be on break.
So they won't know that we're kind of giving
away the farm with such a big discount.
I would love for you to sign up for a membership
at join pacman dot com, but if you want the
biggest discount, just get on my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com.
Monday Memorial Day, you'll get an email telling
you exactly how to sign up.
The David Pakman Show is, of course, a community
and audience supported program.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
get instant access not only to the bonus show.
Speaker 4: The bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else who makes money
to fund.
Speaker 5: Themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: But also to the daily commercial
free audio stream, daily commercial free video
stream.
And you get all of it 6 hours before everybody
else sign up at join Packman dot com.
Let's speak to people people in the audience.
We take calls via discord.
You can go to David Pakman dot com slash discord.
It's all free.
I have nothing to sell you in this particular
case.
Other than a good time.
Let's start today with Ricky from Charlotte.
Ricky, are you reveling in the loss of Madison
Cawthorn in your state?
Speaker 5: You know, I'm actually a little
bit upset.
We never liked him.
But seeing, like, these videos come out, that
kind of normalized him a little bit.
And I mean, you know, seeing like him in,
like, a more candid sort of position and seeing
that that's what took him down.
I really don't like that.
Speaker 1: Is that what you feel?
Is that the discussion in North Carolina,
that it's the personal stuff that took him
down?
Speaker 5: Yes, without a doubt.
Okay.
You know, people are like big, you know, decorum
ninjas and stuff like that.
Yeah.
That definitely took them down anyways.
But David, you know, I wanted to ask you this
and and I want you to answer this as honest
and candidly as possible.
Okay?
I recently kind of had an epiphany looking
at, uh, kind of looking at how bad things
are right now and how bleak the future looks.
And, and this is about everything, you know,
it seems to me like a lot of momentum is with
the right right now how strong and united
they are.
The Republican Party is increasingly going
into an authoritarian fascist direction.
Yes.
On top of that, the problems that we have
with this war, which I really don't like,
how it's it seems to be escalating.
And and the fact that we're still not addressing
big issues like climate change, all of this,
like, really does make me feel kind of like
what Chomsky was saying recently about how
we're getting like the Doomsday Clock is ticking.
So assuming you, like, agree with a lot of
those sentiments, is there anything in spite
of all this that gives you any optimism or
hope with all of this going on?
Speaker 1: I mean, it's it's sort of cliche
at this point, but it's that if you zoom out
a little, it does seem that things are generally
getting better.
And I know that a lot of people, it's very
unpopular.
Now, this is like the Stephen Pink's Pink
Star Pinsker thing.
Is that his name?
And I don't agree.
Stephen.
Yes.
Even the the whole thing of how over time,
you know, death from wars has gone down and
infant mortality has gone down and all of
that stuff.
It doesn't ignore that there's many problems
that we could have already fixed, like hunger,
for example.
But I maintain, just like a general cautious
optimism, particularly with the idea that
young people are actually motivated to find
solutions to a lot of these problems.
And so I maintain a long term optimism, but
I do think the next 8 to 10 years could be
pretty bad.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
I, you know, my my like the bar has gotten
so low for me.
Like, I honestly, like, I don't care about
who wins the next couple of elections.
Mainly just want one the US to still be a
democracy in ten years.
Right.
We haven't the whole world hasn't been destroyed
in a nuclear war and that there can still
be something saved from the planet, that it
will still be inhabitable.
Uh, there's still something we can do to make
it still inhabitable for, like, next.
That's true.
I hope so.
Things that I want to see happen.
Speaker 1: And I'm right with you, Ricky.
I'm right with you there.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you for the call.
There's Ricky from Charlotte.